george osborne has welcomed the latest  growth figures but something else has  happened that's left rather a dent in  the chancellor's coffers and that is  that the eu has demanded that britain  pays an extra 1.7 billion pounds now the  reason for this is because officials  have been looking through the figures  and they believe that the british  economy has fared rather better than  they expected and as a result the uk  needs to pay more money now of course  that's a financial issue for the uk  government but it's also a political one  that impacts david cameron as well not  least because he's facing a very  difficult challenge from ukip in the up  and coming rochester by-election so that  could be difficult because any round  with brussels will play directly into  the hands of nigel farage now  david cameron says that he wants to try  and challenge the ruling but to be frank  his chances of success in that are  rather slim